foreign
I figured it out all right man this is
the perfect amount of clothes
okay for a minimalist to own okay wait
is there is there a question about
clothing no this is a topic okay and so
there was sort of a question I I when I
was moving
I posted a photo I had packed all of my
clothes
and so many people
were so amazed that all my clothes fit
into one moving box yeah
and that to me is the precise amount of
perfect clothes even with all the
jackets for me
yeah
so the size of this room
no it's uh I mean it was I don't own
many clothes and it's fascinating to me
when people are looking for a specific
number like how many t-shirts do you own
I mean you get that question all the
time right because you're always wearing
that black T-shirt right and
the honest answer for me is I own a box
of clothes I don't count how many
clothes I have I own two pairs of jeans
I own I think three pairs of shoes I own
a drawer full of t-shirts I own a drawer
full of underwear the drawer full of
drawers
that's what a dresser is
and so for me the perfect amount of
clothes is is that box one box it was
fascinating one box of happiness it
forced me a fulfillment it forced me to
remove a few pieces that wouldn't fit in
the Box yeah because oh I got an extra
sweatshirt here oh I do wear that it
fits within the 90 90 rule the
minimalist rule book which you can
download for free the minimalists.com
rulebook if you want the 16 rules for a
living with less and yet even though it
fits within that rule
we have a 17th rule thanks to our good
friend Joshua Becker just because you
use a thing doesn't mean you need to own
it and I had a sweatshirt that was just
on a hanger I'm like yeah I'd wear that
probably once a month man but if I got
rid of it would I still be fine of
course I'd still be fine so I'm gonna
let go of that maybe someone else can
get value from it if I donate it yeah
more value than what I'm getting right
now it doesn't mean I want to own no
clothes it doesn't mean this is the
appropriate amount of clothes for
someone else what I've recognized is
that boundary of having one box of
clothes or one drawer full of t-shirts
if I buy another t-shirt now maybe it's
too many because it won't fit in the
drawer anymore and I'm not going to go
out and buy another dresser just to
accommodate one or two new t-shirts and
so for me I recognize this people kept
dming me when I posted this picture and
they're like so is that are those all
the clothes you wear and
um yeah but what about that what is this
what about this what about as though I'm
prescribing sure that you should have
this as well so Ryan what's the perfect
amount of clothes for you I don't know
man I snowboard so I'm gonna probably
need two boxes I would think I mean just
the the jacket and the snow pants and
the boots and all that being that that
alone fits in a box I yeah I don't know
I think I don't think there's a perfect
amount I think there is a constant
deliberation of you know my wardrobe and
some you know I've had a thing that I
wore a pair of pants that I used to wear
I came across it the other day I'm like
wait a minute I don't wear these anymore
because I put them in the donation box
so there are literal Seasons uh for
things but then there's also like
seasons of life for things I have not
let go my parachute pants though
from the fourth grade I'll never let the
Hammer pants yeah kidding man
my dad wouldn't let me wear parachute
pants I was too worldly you're rebelling
now with he has parachute pants on right
now exactly the parachute dish did you
enjoy this Standalone patreon highlight
if so you can listen to full episodes of
the minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free